terry francona not managing he is
currently dealing with
recovery from surgery so sandy alamar jr
is the acting manager for this cleveland
indians team they got a real tough task
today with jack flaherty on the mound
for the cardinals
pitch down opening day when 89 pitches
in that game
then had 25 days between starts
here is another switch hitter jose
ramirez
that one roped towards right field
towards the corner
and that is out of here for ramirez
an absolute shot a rocket into right
field and the indians
picking up right where they left off
last night it's one to nothing in the
first
an absolute bullet off the bout of jose
ramirez down the line and that is a
great sign for the cleveland indians
they hit home runs at them they're 14
and four in game so that's a good start
for them francisco we appreciate you
taking the time man
i know you went to malverde and do you
and urchella that ride the bikes around
orlando
yeah yeah invited on those bike rides
you want to do it you you're into it
keep up roberto perez rides with us and
he usually brings an apple basket
because he's the one picking apples or
the whole time for ramirez hit a one-two
and ramirez sends it into center field
down for a base hit
leone will get the turn around third
base and the throw
home tag by molina it is on target
leon is cut down into remains one to
nothing indians
great throw by harrison bader in center
field it's gonna be a tougher throw but
he throws a perfect one hop strike to
molina to nail leon at home play
harrison bader who's got a great arm and
covers a ton of ground with an
excellent throw and molina the veteran
with the tag
jack flaherty gives them five innings he
kind of got the sense that maybe he'd
want to go out there for one more but
he's done after five innings
this is a hey calm down he did great
gave us a chance and now
it is the dominican republic native of
23 years of age genesis cabrera
02. right back to the curveball and he
wrote santana
oh goodness this isn't about if you're
carlos santana just tip your cow
watch him buckle you don't see a right
hand to hit her buckle
he goes a knuckle curve see his spike up
spike curve
okay i'm gonna go sit down there's the
curve again and he gets another swinging
strikeout back-to-back case after the
walk to lindor
chance for tyler naquin went back to the
fastball
three straight strikeouts to scrambling
door at third still one nothing dumber
the left-hander
mike schilt is going to use austin
gomber in a lot more
high leverage spots hernandez is the guy
you would have loved to have with
runners at first and second and nobody
out
molina picks it fires it de shields is
out what a play by yadier molina
great play by yachty perfect pick
perfect throw in the tag by carpenter
erases the shields big second out and
now gomber can put away hernandez
a 1-2 on the ground for
edmond how about that houdini act after
the first two men in the frame
walked the defense with a little bit of
a pick up still one nothing
carrasco with the strikeout to close out
a one two three inning
he's retired seven in a row carrasco
with a good pitch to get him swinging
his third strikeout a back-to-back case
for carrasco and there are two down here
in the fifth carrasco just dominated
o'neill with three pitches good morning
good afternoon good night kid
a one run lead for the cleveland indians
bullpen which has been
outstanding and james karanczak might be
at the top of the list of ridiculous
because of what he brings to the table
in terms of velocity and movement here's
matt carpenter guy who's been one of the
top hitters in baseball over the course
of his career
to the fastball carpenter to right
that's going to drop
in front of naquin for a base hit matt
carpenter has tied this game at one in
the seven
tries to go up but he doesn't get it
high enough and he throws it right down
the middle carpenter gets on top of it
i thought that was a ball that we were
going to have a dive and maybe a
possible catch but instead
naked backs up and lets it fall in front
of him for another hit by the cardinal
the ageless wonder the silver-haired
oliver perez at 39 years of age
he's trying to send this game to extras
there's a 2-2
and he got him with the slider a one two
three
perez ninth inning the x ratings we go
indians and cardinals tied up at one a
piece and
john gant is on for the tenth time this
year
sandy leone is going to get an
opportunity to try and bunt it there's
the bunt again on three and one
puts it down gant fires the third tag
applied by
carpenter that's the second out that the
shields has made at third base in this
game he was caught stealing in the
seventh and this time
the bunt pushed too hard right back to
gann who blitzes one over to get to
shields
got a review on this play that's a big
run too if somehow you can get a review
and see if the shields was in there
somehow then you got the
go ahead and run aboard with nobody out
unless carpenter just completely whiffs
on the tag here i see what they
might think they see but still looks
like he's out but it did look like
the left arm the kind of inside of the
forearm is what carpenter got a piece of
before the shields touched the back
nick whitgrin will come on to try to
keep this game at one a piece
runner at third switch hitter batting
lefty 2-1
carlson sends it towards left racing
over
allen did he slide and make it no he did
not make the catch
first things first it was probably
better off that he
didn't make the catch on a slide because
that would have allowed father an
opportunity to score but
she kind of crashed into that wall he i
don't know if he was pointing at his
knee or he was just pointing to say it
was foul
i dropped it yeah he did not make the
catch obviously fowler still the winning
run
at third de young skies it
tosses the bat away ramirez has it and
the bases are left loaded by the
cardinals
tyler naquin will lead off the indians
12th naquin into the cap right center
field and down for a base hit right on
cue
freeman will score the indians have
taken the lead here in the 12th inning
he scores easily as the ball goes into
the gap naked with a
stand up double to put the indians up
two 2-1 now here's carpenter who has the
lone rbi for st
louis swings away first pitch santana
fair ball did he step on the back yes
and now molina caught between third and
home
he must have thought it was a foul ball
they've got him in a rundown and
more base running miscues molina thought
that it was a foul ball and santana just
came over and helped to finish off the
double play to end the game in the 12.
mike schilt obviously out there to talk
to the managers the indians are already
celebrating
that play right there sums up the last
three half innings for the cardinals
with base running mistakes
so that's a double play with a base
running miscue by the cardinals to
end the game the indians finish it off
in a 2-1
final in 12.